jeremy renner may no longer have his own
app but hey now he has his own show
hawkeye on disney plus is very fun but
after the first two episodes we have
questions like what's up with kate
bishop's mom's fiance's uncle's death
and who's a good boy let's explore
hawkeye episode 1 starts off with a bang
or hundreds of them you could say as
we're transported back in time to the
battle of new york from the original
avengers film after we get a brief
glimpse into the shaky marriage of young
kate bishop's parents eleanor and derek
bishop their swanky penthouse starts
shaking and eventually crumbling as the
chittari decimate the buildings of new
york a young kate is on her own in the
penthouse as she gets separated from her
parents and the chitauri almost takes
her out but we see that an arrow from
hawkeye takes down the small alien ship
before it claims her kate spots hawkeye
on the roof of a nearby building
identifying her savior who then leaps
from the building and shoots a grapple
arrow a throwback to a famous clint
moment from the avengers it's at this
moment that kate becomes inspired thanks
to the heroic efforts of hawkeye on that
roof he saved her life and she admits to
her mom at her father's funeral that she
wants a bow and arrow thanks to
hawkeye's heroism that day in new york
kate takes up archery and other skills
including karate and pencey without
clint there would be no kate bishop in
the mcu
one of the goals of episode one of
hawkeye is to explain to the viewer
what's going on with clint since we last
saw him in avengers end game it's been
more than two years since his last mcu
scene as he attended tony stark's
funeral but he was reunited with his
family he is still with his kids as
hawkeye kicks off as we see the foursome
attend rogers the musical without mom
watching the silly musical turns out to
be slightly triggering for clint who is
clearly annoyed at the nonsense of it
all yo honey i know
i know what happens i was there
he knew it wasn't there it's that guy
he's mostly in his feelings about the
loss of his best friend natasha as we
see his mind wander after the musical
version natasha starts cartwheeling
around it's here that he takes a break
and leaves to go to the restroom and we
also see him fumble with his hearing aid
it turns out clint has suffered some
severe hearing loss in his left ear
thanks to his adventures with the
avengers it looks like clint is making
up for lost time with his kids and is
spending the days leading up to
christmas with them laura is off at
their farmhouse and explains their
separation by suggesting this is
supposed to be clint's one-on-one time
with his kids of course clintus pulled
away from his family after spotting kate
on tv in the ronin suit from avengers
end game
we're introduced to two villains in the
first episode of hawkeye one is the
tracksuit mafia who are truly living up
to their marvel comics hype we don't
really get a sense of who they are and
why they're so angry but we do know that
they had run-ins with ronin when he was
still on his killing rampage after the
snap they chased down kate after she
fumbles their heist of the secret black
market auction but clint comes to save
the day after he sees his ronin suit
back on the streets of new york kate
snatched it during the auction chaos
while jack made off with ronin's sword
speaking of jack this is another villain
we need to keep our eye on he has
suspiciously wooed kate's widow mother
and the pair are now engaged he loves
swords which is no surprise given jack
is pulled directly from the marvel
comics character jacques du kane aka
swordsman a former mentor and teacher of
clans jacques has no connection with
kate bishop in the comic so this is an
interesting twist hawkeye is giving us
while we don't know what jack is up to
in episode 1 his creepiness alone lets
us know he's up to no good it's already
suspected that he's involved in the
death of his uncle armand and there's
some talk at the auction of a sizable
inheritance while episode 1 served as an
introduction to kate her mother eleanor
jack the tracksuit mafia oh and we can't
forget lucky the pizza dog it gave us a
good idea of where hawkeye is going and
themes that will be carried throughout
clint is clearly still dealing with the
grief of losing natasha while he also
seems to be trying to cover up his past
as ronin he still has enemies from his
days as the vigilante and they're coming
back to haunt him thanks to his number
one fan kate kate a vigilante in her own
right is now working to uncover the
mystery of her future step dad and the
murder of armond iii who in the comics
is actually jack's father she's become
the target of the tracksuit mafia who
are clearly not the men in charge we
suspect kate and clint will find out
they somehow have a connection to one
another especially given how all these
characters intertwine in the comics and
then there's the lingering mystery of
that watch which is very important to
the tracksuit mafia for some unknown
reason we've got 90 seconds to find a
watch everything else is second there
episode 2 picks up immediately after
episode 1 as clint barton is pulling the
ronin mask off of kate bishop in an
alley clint is keen on getting his suit
back from kate so they head to her
apartment to hide out for a moment while
still in shock that she's with the real
hawkeye kate changes and hands the suit
over to clint unfortunately those pesky
tracksuit mafia members have tracked
them down and start throwing molotov
cocktails through her apartment window
the apartment eventually catches fire
causing the duo to abandon the ronin
suits and now kate and clint are on the
run
once the tracksuit mafia sets kate's
apartment on fire the duo has to bolt
and head somewhere safe kate decides to
go to her aunt's apartment since she's
out of town clint forces kate to hide
out there while he heads back to
retrieve the suit he finds out one of
the firemen stole it which is just
another unnecessary obstacle for clint
to overcome he comes back to visit kate
and helps her patch up a wound and we
get a peek at how clint might become a
father figure to his new friend the
following day clint has to ditch his
kids as he sends him off to be with
their very understanding mom he revisits
kate back at their hideout and then they
go their separate ways but not before
exchanging phone numbers clint thinks
this is the last time he'll see kate and
begs her only to call if she has an
emergency it's now clint's mission to
retrieve the ronin suit and figure out
why the tracksuit mafia is stirring up
trouble yet again he travels to a
live-action roleplay event to find his
suit where he suspects the thieving
firefighter will be wearing it clint
must sign up and participate in the
event to get to the firefighter which
turns into one of the best slow motion
bits ever seen in the mcu as clint fake
slices and dices some hilarious
adversaries after a duel with the thief
clint is finally in possession of the
ronin suit again
back at kate's mom's penthouse jack is
back doing very jack things he continues
to fool kate's mom while not bullying
his soon-to-be daughter-in-law but he
also doesn't seem to care kate ends up
challenging him to a fencing match where
he pretends to be the lesser competitor
as kate yells at jack to stop letting
her win she eventually tricks him into
showing off his true talent and uses
this as a way to prove he's some kind of
liar sorry for scaring you into telling
the truth
obviously jack is a liar but we're still
not sure what his true intentions are
he's still in possession of the ronin
sword but it's unclear what his plan is
after his fencing match with kate he
offers her a butterscotch one which
matches those in a bowl at armand's
house from episode 1. this appears to be
enough proof for kate that jack killed
ramon but in reality all it suggests is
that jack has been to his uncle's house
before jack's involvement with his
uncle's death is still unclear but
things don't look good
while kate is having some family fun
clint sets himself up to be kidnapped by
the tracksuit mafia he tells his wife on
the phone that he's doing a catch and
release which laura points out is
classic gnat after luring the goons to
him glint is taken to a secret location
where he continues to tell the gangsters
he wants to talk to the person in charge
after realizing clint's in trouble kate
comes to help after tracking his
location but falls through the roof of
the building and causes a mess instead
as kate and clint are tied up by the
gang one of the mafia members goes into
a speaker-filled room to get the boss as
the base in the background booms we get
our first look at maya lopez aka echo
it's a briefest of glimpses as the
screen cuts the credits after we see her
face but it promises us an even bigger
episode for next week echo who already
has her own series coming to disney plus
is a deaf hero who is mainly known for
her role in the daredevil comics the
adoptive daughter of kingpin echo's
appearance in hawkeye might hint that we
could be getting a second go-round with
wilson fisk from the netflix daredevil
series or the mcu could remix her origin
the way it's done with plenty of other
heroes while it looks like ekko is the
villain now we can almost guarantee she
won't be there is either a bigger threat
we haven't met or jack truly is the big
bad the biggest takeaway from hawkeye
episode 2 still no yelena biloba from
black widow as promised but we expect
she's right around the corner
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
hawkeye are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]